heute ist mal wieder krone gipfel wieder
mal am mittag um 1 ist der erste in
diesem jahr es wird weitere
einschränkungen geben die zweite impfung
soll ab jetzt weniger wert sein
zumindest in der gastronomie gastronomie
wir schauen uns den entwurf jetzt mal
genauer an teilweise hat ihn
das sind sie gewohnt von bild das was da
heute auf den tisch kommt beim corona
gipfel das sehen sie schon vorher bei
bild das ist das papier einmal groß für
sie auf dem bildschirm gezogen sie sehen
dass hier der beschlussvorschlag also
noch einmal zur wahl und das ding ist
noch nicht beschlossen aber darüber
beraten die ministerpräsidenten und die
bundesregierung ab 13 uhr heute und in
der regel gehen die zentralen dinge aus
diesem papier daneben nachher auch so
durch wir schauen auf zwei ganz
entscheidende punkte das eine betrifft
die quarantäne oder es war andere
betrifft die korona regeln vor allen
dingen für geimpfte also wir schauen auf
einen ganz wesentlichen satz der hier im
papier auf der seite 2 steht der heißt
nämlich der durch erst und zwei tim
vermittelte immunschutz ist bei der
omicron variante eingeschränkt also die
bundesregierung hier in diesem fall das
kanzleramt gesteht ein dass das was
bisher als vollständiger impfschutz galt
also erst und zweiten vor der omicron
variante nur noch bedingt schützt und
das hat eben jetzt politische folgen
schauen wir auf punkt 4 in diesem papier
das dann ab 13 uhr auf dem tisch liegt
denn das betrifft vor allen dingen die
gastronomie das betrifft restaurants
cafés und kneipen da soll man nämlich ab
dem 15 januar dass es noch nicht ganz
klar deswegen den eckigen klammern
darüber über dieses datum wird noch
gestritten nachher aber ab mitte januar
soll man nur noch dann ins restaurant
und in die kneipe können wenn man
zweifach geimpft ist und obendrauf noch
den booster hat oder ein tagesaktuellen
test vorweisen kann zweig plus heißt das
ganze ding dann also für restaurants und
cafés und nicht nur regional sondern in
ganz deutschland das heißt die
zweitimpfung
wird abgewertet das reicht nicht mehr
aus alleine um ins restaurant und in die
kneipe zu gehen es braucht obendrein
tagesaktuellen test oder eben den
nachweis über die booster impfung das
ding das soll heute mittag dann
beschlossen werden das kanzleramt olaf
scholz will das auf jeden fall schon
einmal und wir schauen auf den zweiten
großen punkt der findet sich hier unter
achtens wieder da geht es um die
quarantäne regeln derzeit gilt ja noch
wenn man kontakt zu einem corona
infizierten mit der omicron variante
hatte dann ist man 14 tage erstmal raus
egal ob man gesund oder krank ist selbst
ein negativer test reicht dann derzeit
noch nicht aus so das wird definitiv
geändert unklar noch genau wie denn die
regeln die hier in diesem papier in
dieser beschlussvorlage festgehalten
sind die sind reichlich kompliziert
versuchen wir es mal hier es gilt dass
diejenigen kontaktpersonen die einen
vollständigen impfschutz durch die
auffrischungsimpfung also durch den
booster vorweisen von der quarantäne
ausgenommen sein sollen und dann gelten
spezielle regeln für alle übrigen die
sollen sich nämlich nach zehn tagen raus
testen können aus dieser quarantäne und
ganz besondere regeln gelten dann noch
für alle die die noch zur schule gehen
oder in die kinderbetreuung also für
kita-kinder die sollen sich nämlich weil
sie sowieso dauernd getestet werden nach
fünf tagen mit einem pc herunter antigen
schnelltest aus dieser quarantäne
künftig raus testen können also für
unterschiedliche bevölkerungsgruppen
gelten dann wieder unterschiedliche
quarantäne regeln das noch reichlich
kompliziert klar ist aber wahr die
quarantäne regeln wird gelockert und bei
den regeln für nur zweifach geimpfte
wird mit blick auf die gastronomie
verschärft dass das zentrale war es beim
corona gipfel heute mittag auf den tisch
kommt neben einem vermutlich heftigen
streit über die impfpflicht patricia und
nadja aswad bei dir im studio
ja ganz genau nadja aswad aus unseren
politik ressort ist jetzt zwar schön
dass du hier bist ja leid dass eben
gerade vorgestellte steht in dieser
diesem beschlussvorschlag der auch bei
uns ja auf dem tisch liegt zweig plus
für restaurant- und gastro ist das
überhaupt umzusetzen meinst du da wird
man sich darauf einigen können dass ist
ja schon eine harte maßnahme gestern
haben wir mit bayerns ministerpräsident
markus söder gesprochen hat gesagt
irgendwie kommt diese
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz eh viel zu
früh da die zahlen ja noch gar nicht so
richtig hier belastbar sind ihm wäre
lieber gewesen man hätte das erst eine
woche später gemacht wie groß ist also
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass man sich auf
all das was hier drin steht überhaupt
einig ja die große befürchtung patricia
ist dass die zahlen in wirklichkeit ja
viel höher sind als wir jetzt gerade
wissen weil eben über die feiertage
weniger getestet wurde weil weniger
menschen beim arzt waren und dass wir
erst mitte januar ungefähr wissen wie es
eigentlich wirklich steht um die zahlen
jetzt gerade die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
man sich darauf einigt ist glaube ich
sehr hoch weil man tatsächlich davon
ausgeht dass das der beste und richtige
weg ist es sind ja auch in vielen
bundesländern schon kneipen und bars
geschlossen worden
bei den restaurants zeichnet sich aber
auch ab dass das ein großes problem
werden wird für die gastwirte für die
betreiber von gastronomie die dehoga
chefin hat jetzt schon erklärt das ist
eine unfassbare last für die für die
betreiber von restaurants weil du halt
einfach nicht weiß wie viele kunden und
noch kommen wenn sie denn zeitgleich
auch noch ins sich testen lassen müssen
und den frischen test mitbringen das ist
natürlich mit großem aufwand verbunden
und dann überlegt man sich vielleicht
dreimal gehe ich heute abend essen gehe
ich zum lunch noch mal raus oder bleibe
ich einfach daheim und kauf mir was und
das ist natürlich für die gastwirte die
jetzt nach der ganzen corona phase schon
massiv gebeutelt sind ein riesen großes
risiko und obendrein ist das doch so was
wie die booster pflicht durch die
hintertür mittlerweile muss man den
deutschen doch ganz klar sagen es reicht
nicht mehr aus nur zweifach geimpft zu
sein jetzt was bisher als vollständiger
impfschutz reicht das könnt ihr im
grunde vergessen ihr braucht den booster
um in restaurants und kneipen
reinzukommen und das wird doch demnächst
auch noch weiter ausgeweitet also
klartext die politik wird uns heute
mittag sagen zweifach geimpft reicht
nicht mehr aus genau das stimmt da hast
du völlig recht ob es dann am ende drei
impfungen bleiben oder ob es vier oder
sogar fünf werden wir werden das sehen
es wird ja sogar die vierte im vorstand
diskutiert es ist alles noch ein
bisschen im schwange aber klar ist dass
die zwei garantiert nicht mehr
ausreichen werden
dass also der kurzer ausblick dieses
thema ist es uns den ganzen tag
begleiten wird und 13 uhr geht es los
nadja aswad vielen herzlichen dank für
deinen besuch vor uns liegt sehr
beschlussvorschlag ist heute für den
corona gipfel bund und länder kommen
zusammen werden so sieht es jetzt aus
härtere maßnahmen beschließen auch wenn
die zahlen die das rk ii derzeit
herausgibt noch gar nicht ein wirklich
umfassendes bild abliefern so gibt das
rkw selbst zu und wie man gerade das
live bild vom kanzleramt gesehen also da
steigt der korona gipfel dann ab 13 uhr
vom kanzler mit den ministerpräsidenten
und bild ist für sie wie immer live
dabei